there are three kinds of donuts sugary
ring donuts
sugary jelly-filled donuts and then
they're the ones that are really bad for
your health
[Music]
these ones
well i can see why people pay money to
watch this
[Applause]
but take any friction fighting hijinks
to the roads and it's a serious hazard
for motorists
and for trees they were okay
but extremely lucky so you should never
attempt this
but off the road and in the hands of an
expert donuts
are a master class in static and kinetic
friction
our driver hits the gas hard and turns
sharply
the excessive torque at the rear wheels
overcomes static friction between the
tires and the ground
so they become subject to kinetic
friction which offers less resistance
the reduced grip allows centrifugal
force to slide the wheels in a circular
path
like the ring of a doughnut
[Music]
so not just risky but scientifically
tricky to pull off
although not everyone seems to think so
i mean this guy thinks he's got the
science down but in fact he hasn't lost
traction at his back tires at all
he's just using rollers see which does
reduce the risk of kinetic friction
burning up the tires but
doesn't make it less dangerous
it's a bit late for that ah the parking
lot doughnut
using kinetic friction and centripetal
force to drift into a space
like a glove having successfully turned
static friction to kinetic at the rear
wheels
he then momentarily let up the power on
those wheels and went back to static
so he stopped circling and went straight
there are better ways to park a car
you